[Applaudissements]
alors michel vous allez devoir effectuer
cinq donc se rassurer vos michel pas de
costumes pas de perruque rien voilà
juste des gens qui vont venir danser
avec vous pendant 15 secondes vous aurez
15 secondes de danse à chaque fois et
vous allez lancer avec des gens qui vont
apparaître
là vous allez voir il y aura plusieurs
danses il y aura des jeux aux costumes
et le premier qui va venir danser avec
vous je vous demande d'accueillir
regarder
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
la piscine
[Applaudissements]
ça nous agace je me demande si j'ai tout
laissé comme c'est ça oui j'étais le
plombier il est pas mal c'est lui
[Rires]
attention c'est une bosseuse elle
accueille l'attend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça c'est dans ce domaine que je sais
c'est que je n'ai retraite c'est bien
l'interpréter n'a pas très bien j'aime
beaucoup je vois d'habitude c'est une
danse pour toi c'est ça c'est du
bastingage orient il y avait un peu de
chance mais là je puisse être très bête
ça vous va très bien berné une souris
l'attention
[Applaudissements]
m
joie
il
là
et
[Musique]
ces mots michel
michel d'ailleurs à la nouvelle de leur
modem ça et on sait la steppe supérieur
mathieu dit non ça ouais c'est vrai vous
pouvez y aller un partout bien sûr la
suisse y aller il savait tablettes sont
belles c'est petit mais là ce petit coin
à les montrer mais là d'accord m et lui
la fille michèle ils sont très bien
foutu des chroniqueurs oui oui c'est
mieux c'est pour reçu pour rattraper le
corps du patron coeur battant le 4e
d'ailleurs c'est une femme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais valérie mais michel jeanne ou
flamengo
[Musique]
franchement vous êtes une fraîcheur mais
hollywood chewing gum vraiment vraiment
magnifique
on a deux dernières danseuse qui vont
danser avec elle à vous allez vous
régaler à je vous le dis la plus simple
vous régaler c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
mais pis c'est tout
cheney
ouah
jaloux chambre de mon fils
ça suffit michel michel c'est plutôt
tranquille à piau n'est qu'une heure
d'entraînement
enfin en 50 ans mais si michel drucker
qui étaient avec nous
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi que vous regardez danse avec
les stars cette année parce que vous
m'avez pas mise avec les femmes et les
filles sexy à on se demande bien
pourquoi
non mais vous vous inquiétez pas ça va
venir votre tour va venir vous n'hésitez
pas vous levez la main dès que j'avais
un truc à dire oui au jeu demain michel
quelle dose